For entrance to this museum,
it would have been nice to have an automated discount.
Let's build a program that calculates
the correct ticket price for entrance to this museum.
The ticket price should generally be $10 per person but also include a discount,
so that it's only $5 in three cases.
One, for young people aged 15 and under.
Two, for older people aged greater than 60.
And three, if you're a student of some sort like you,
then you also get the discount.
So how can we build a program like this?
First, let's keep track of our ticketPrice by declaring it as a variable,
and we'll give it an initial general value of 10,
which we can change to our discount price of five in our code in a bit.
Then, to tell if someone qualifies for a discount,
we'll also need variables that keep track of
someone's age and whether or not they're a student.
I've chosen to represent age as a whole number, as an int.
And whether a person is a student or not can be either true or false.
So that will be a boolean.
So let's say we have access to the value of these two variables,
but we don't exactly know what their value will be.
Now, let's consider our first discount condition,
that someone is 15 years old or younger.
We basically want to turn this into an if statement,
where a test condition checks if age is less than or equal to 15.
And if that's true, we execute code to give this
person a discount and set our ticket price to $5.
So to write our first test for ages 15 and under as a boolean comparison, we'd say,
if age is less than or equal to 15,
then if this is true, inside our if,
we want to set the ticketPrice to our discount value of five.
And at the end of our code,
I want to print out the value of ticketPrice for us to see.
Now, if we run this code and the age variable is less than 15 say,
10 years old, we'll pass our if test condition and our ticketPrice will be set to five,
then we'll print this value out.
But if our age is greater than 15 like 25,
we don't enter our if statement,
and our ticketPrice will remain
our initial general value of 10 and that value we'll print out.
Our other two discount conditions,
we'll be checking if someone's age is greater than not greater than and
equal to 60 years old and if a person is a student.
Let's complete those checks in the following.